hello hello good morning good afternoon
good evening good middle of the night no
matter where you are tuning in from we
welcome you
to ask doc life
just wait for a minute as everybody is
jumping in and
everything is connecting i love seeing
so many people so early in the show and
just as a reminder if you are on with us
today and you would like to ask dr
wellick a question
go to your zoom menu
click on
reactions
and you will find the option to raise
your virtual hand so if you're like this
i'm sorry i can't see you
so we need to raise your virtual hand
that way it comes up um in my menu
and i know that you want to ask a
question
so
my name
is rebecca dukes kozak and i welcome you
to
ask doc live
so myself and my friends ruthel and
sanchez nasima omar heather bowen dr
judy reynolds
and our special guest dr joel wallach
are here to
provide this as a tool as a resource
to help you get the knowledge that
is not shared everywhere
and that this knowledge
actually
is providing you information
and solutions to the most common health
issues around the world
around the world
and it is my honor to be able to host
for the next two hours this program
sharing this information with solutions
not just telling you what's wrong but
actual solutions
so in this program
we do have a chat make sure that you
have that chat option open if you're on
live with us
our co-hosts are going to be sharing
valuable information and helping you
find
the names of the products that uh dr
wallach will be mentioning in today's
program and also some helpful hints on
things that you can do in your daily
life
that will improve and add to
not take away
from
what your cells need in order to
regenerate because you know they're
gener regenerating all the time we're
getting new cells in fact i've even
heard that in a seven year period
every single cell of your body
is brand new
at some point in time of course not die
off and
be new all
at once but
it's amazing how our bodies can go from
two cells and multiply over and over and
over to create what we have today and
depending on what we put in our mouths
and what we have in our environments
determine
how those cells are going to react
and how our genes are going to be
expressed which we're going to go a
little bit more into the genetic thing
in just a moment
but if you are on live with us
um
this is a safe place
we want to make sure that if you are
invited specifically by somebody and
this is even if you're watching the
replay excuse me on that
make sure that you get back with the
person that shared this program with you
they have an
invested love
in making sure that you get information
to help you and your family and your
community
so this is information we don't want to
keep to ourselves and as you are
listening i know
for a fact you're going to want to share
as well
now the content of this program is to
provide educational information only on
the importance of nutrition and
supplementation
folks
their food supplies around the world are
null and void of what the body really
really needs
fda
has their whole
recommended daily allowances
that's to keep us alive but not
necessarily thrive
and in this program we will be sharing
nutritional options that are available
to go beyond that just survive mode and
into thriving
now the statements that are provided
through this program have not been
evaluated by the food and drug products
discussed are not intended to diagnose
treat cure or prevent any diseases
and the information again is contained
contained on this zoom is for
informational purposes only if you are
pregnant nursing or taking medication
we are to advise you to consult with
your hair health care professional
before starting any nutritional
supplement
we're using food as medicine
that's a key point folks
and our good doctor who we have on with
us each and every friday
has been very instrumental
in
i don't i don't want to say suing but
that's what it is when somebody's in the
wrong he calls him out
and makes it right folks
nine victories
against the fda and making sure that
nutrients are being added to things like
our baby formula
so that our babies can be healthy
which i know he's going to go a little
bit into
but back to the genetics thing okay what
we put in our mouths what we have in our
environment
like i said it affects how our genes are
expressed
and this gentleman has proven he is one
of the co-founders
of the science of epigenetics
where it has totally debunked
the genetic theory
and you can find that all in his book
epigenetics
dr joel wallick
welcome
welcome welcome
well thank you rebecca it's such an
honor to be able to host you each and
every friday
i mean not only are you one of the
co-founders one of the founding fathers
of epigenetics
you're a recipient of the claw schwartz
commemorative medal the lifetime
achievement
on natural medicine and flora trophy i
always have a hard time with that world
word from the united nations
i mean you have so many accolades plus
having your thesis
in the smithsonian as a national
treasure
and
you
you're not above
joining us each and every week
and sharing this information to others
and i just can't thank you enough
for allowing us to
come into your friday every single
friday so that we can share the
information that you've shared through
your research
with the world
well thank you so very much rebecca
that's just quite an introduction i
can't thank you enough for all the kind
words and it takes teamwork to do all
this stuff and
and so um i can't thank you enough for
allowing me to participate
and so basically what i want to do is
talk about something very common
we've talked about it before but i'm
going to come at a little bit different
direction today i want to talk about
arthritis osteoporosis
and i want to talk to people who are
already going to orthopedic medical
doctors who are going to chiropractors
massage therapists and they're getting
some kind of
professional
um
physical management or dietary
management or whatever of things going
on in their joints and their bones and
cartilage and ligaments and tendons and
connective tissue and so forth
right now in the united states we have
something like 332 million 228
200 citizens
okay
and um
we have
58.5 million cases of what's diagnosed
as arthritis arthritis as the name
implies deals with the joints
okay
24 of americans
have arthritis diagnosed arthritis
there's juvenile arthritis um for kids
under the age of 16 right now we have
300 000 cases 300 000
one-third of a billion
cases of juvenile arthritis the united
states now this
originally goes back
to between like
and today
okay
back in the 1850s uh people were
beginning to switch around and not use
wood for fuel and coal for fuel and
stuff like that
and um we had been doing that for
millions of years and of course the
ashes from wood and coal
uh
were put into gardens as a fertilizer
and the ashes were like 98 minerals and
two or three percent carbon
a grandma would put some of these wood
ashes into our food
as a spice but also we're getting those
minerals for thousands and thousands of
years
well when we went to electricity
uh in 1882 three o'clock in the
afternoon monday september 4th 1882 and
i have a book written about this event
it's called hell's kitchen
where we switch from wood stoves and
fireplaces to electricity
nobody said okay well we got to make up
the difference here because people are
not getting those wood ashes and coal
ashes anymore as a source of minerals
nobody said anything like that
okay and kids began
began to get a disease in the 1800s
called rickets now ricketts was just
osteoporosis and kids that you know
strides we talk about today they had bow
legs they had hip problems and knee
problems and back problems and shoulder
problems their teeth were all falling
out they're just kids okay it's called
rickets
and um in the 1920s early 1920s 1920
nutritionists began to put vitamin d3
which they had just discovered into milk
and put them on the shelf in grocery
stores and up until that time
kids had given up drinking milk and gone
to
carbonated soft drinks they went to
juices and there was no minerals in
there right and so they weren't getting
any minerals and so they were getting
rickets and all these problems
and so when they started putting the
vitamin d3 in the milk all of a sudden
the rickets went away
it was a miraculous thing
okay
and so this is very very clever stuff
and it's one of those things where it
just shows you
that if you give the body what it needs
it will do well
well right now as of today each year we
spend
626.8 billion dollars a year just to
treat the symptoms of arthritis what
626.8 billion dollars just to treat the
symptoms of arthritis we do not
spend any of that money to prevent or
cure
arthritis just to treat the symptoms
okay so the
human population america has been turned
into a dairy herd for the medical system
okay it sounds pretty rough but that's
the way it is
then
um
also annually uh you know people talk
about osteoporosis and you can and of
course
uh my book uh the news cd which is done
with rebecca and myself
uh it's all in your head
i thought there was 25 diseases were
caused by obviously approach the skull
squeeze the spinal nerves and
spinal cord and also the cranial nerves
but actually it turns out there's like
37 different diseases
they're caused by obviously approaches
call they never teach anything about
osteoporosis
in in the medical school so that's why
we have the book in the cd we have the
set and if you buy the set you get a
discount you have to buy them together
you have to buy the book and the cd at
the same time you get the discount if
you buy the book and the cd a week apart
you don't get the discount okay
well for osteoporosis which is just
again mineral deficiencies of the long
parts of the bones
the joints is called arthritis but
osteoporosis is everywhere
and when you look at just the
expenditure from three communities in
the u.s united states canada and the
european union
each year that community spends 6.5
trillion with a t 6.5 trillion dollars
just to treat the symptoms of
osteoporosis not to prevent it or cure
it i mean that drove me crazy when i
heard that one that means 2.2 trillion
dollars is being spent by america each
year just to treat the symptoms of
osteoporosis and we're talking about
cortisone and prednisone and and you
know we're talking also about
um
things like
mineral drinks and so on
and we have a whole bunch of them you
know we've got the rebounders first
drink with a hundred nutrients in it 75
of which are minerals we got the rebound
in the can we got the rebound in the
canister canister has 36 servings in
there we have the sticks um
rebound
30 in a box we have a new one out
kids love it because it tastes like
cherry juice it's called mineral sticks
okay it has 75 minerals in it but it
also has collagen in there to help
rebuild cartilage and ligaments and
tendons and connective tissue and bone
matrix and bone marrow and so forth
and so there's 30 of those sticks in
that box
and so you want to get those and you
know you know give a little two or three
of those kids each day
and um but start adding
okay to anybody who's getting treatment
by any health professional
okay whether they're a chiropractor
or a massage therapist or um
a nurse practitioner or
a
medical doctor who specializes in
orthopedics and so forth get them on
these nutrients okay
um the um
healthy bone and joint pack we started
out
gosh you got to be 30 years ago
as the
let's see here it started out as the pig
pack
okay the pig arthritis farm when people
say why did you call it that why'd you
give it a big arthritis pharma that's
because i wasn't a physician yet and i
didn't want the doctors attacking me so
i gave my program for helping to rebuild
bone and cartilage and ligaments and
tendons
from arthritis and osteoporosis i put
the name pig arthritis formula in there
so that i say well see i'm telling you
i'm a veterinarian here so it's the pig
arthritis formula which became the
healthy bone and joint pack once i
became a physician
okay
and so
that's the history there now
we want everybody to make sure that this
information gets out there
and of course you pay wholesale prices
for the healthy bone and joint pack they
host fill prices for all of our products
if you're on auto ship i will pay the
shipping
okay so you're going to save a lot of
money if you get on auto ship
and
um
and just remember that 6.5 trillion
dollars we're spending in the u.s canada
and the eu each year is just to treat
the symptoms and when people are just
getting cortisone and prednisone they're
happy because they do get pain relief
they get inflammation relief
but the process keeps going forward in
fact in some some cases will be
accelerated by the use of cortisone
prednisone even though your pain
is lessening
the percentage of mineral loss increases
we use protozoan cortisol
okay and so it's one of those things
where okay
if you're happy with just relief
and you don't mind you know two three
years down the line you're gonna get a
double hip replacement or double knee
replacement or some back surgery or
something like that go for it but if you
want to avoid all those really serious
treatments like surgeries and joint
replacements and stuff like that later
on
throw in
the healthy bone and joint pack if
finances are a problem throw in the
healthy bone joint pack you know one per
hundred pounds of body weight
if you
you know don't have a financial problem
use the healthy brain and heart pack in
the msm
um throw in
the collagen peptides or both whether
you're going to use the
healthy bone and joint pack are
the healthy bone and joint pack um
okay
our
are the ultimate daily classic tablets
okay all that kind of stuff you want to
make sure
that you're getting the nutrition
okay and so when you do that
your bones will begin to heal themselves
the cartilage will begin to heal itself
the tendons and ligaments will heal
themselves just remember
the covering of the brain is made from
connective tissue the covering of the
heart is made from connective tissue
heart valves are made from connective
tissue
the muscles
in your intestines are held in place by
connective tissue
connective tissue is in the skin
okay if you have white grain silver hair
regardless of your age that has nothing
with aging it's due to a nutritional
deficiency it's the red warning light
just like the red warning light in the
dashboard of the car
so i urge you
to again
at the very minimum in addition to
taking your 90 essential nutrients take
the healthy bone and joint pack
okay
but if you if money's not a financial
issue go ahead and take the healthy
brain and heart pack throw in msm
throw in the collagen peptides
um
be sure you're throwing in
let's see here uh oh
i said the collagen peptide yeah okay
and then also
beyond osteofx i also take the collagen
uh or the glucogel which is our original
collagen we had in the uh osteofx and
also in the um
when you have the
healthy
bone and joint pack okay how the bone
joint pact that's the collagen comes
from
uh
one source well the collagen and the
um
uh
okay the collagen and our newest
products comes from four sources okay it
comes from
um
fish poultry sheep and beef that's our
collagen peptides and of course we have
the collagen from beef in the mineral
sticks again and so i take four
of those four or five of those
collagen
tablets
twice a day
and then of course i throw in extra
calcium in this and the other i mean i
take a lot of stuff
and that's why you know i'm 82 years old
and i don't have
joint pot i do have an injury but i
don't have any arthritis or osteoporosis
or anything like that i have very little
gray white or silver hair for 83.
okay
uh let's see here with all that
um
let's see here we've got a few moments
uh left
um
in this part of this segment here before
we go to questions and so i want to
throw this to rebecca rebecca do you
have any questions regarding the things
i've said here before we go to callers
well dr wellick it's very interesting
that you're talking about the arthritis
today and started out with the pigpen
because that's where i started and i
have people ask me
pickpack
what's that
and i was like well that's one of our
original
you know packages and it's still
available
now why wait on earth would he call
something a pig back and you just
explained it you started out as a
veterinarian
and when people think of veterinarians
doctor well like they think dogs and
cats but no no
you don't do anything small
you go really big
so i'm i'm glad that you covered that
because that'll give us that gives us a
little bit of background in history
on
the development of the different
products that were just have been
designed
to help people with bone and joint
issues
and
this morning i had my
uh unflavored greek yogurt full fat
i had a scoop of collagen i had a scoop
of rebound i had a scoop of our collagen
peptides joint health
which also includes additional vitamin a
calcium vitamin c
hyaluronic acid msm glucosamine
chondroitin
and people like well why do you take all
that
well folks i'm 51 years old
and i think i when i look at pictures
of now and even 20 30 years ago
i look younger
so i think it's not just helping with my
bone and joints which i had a lot of
bone joint issues
a lot
and i think it's helping
with my skin what do you think doc
well i think you look like you're in
your 30s and for somebody who's 45 50
years old you look like you're in your
30s and you're just you know had that
beautiful smile and the energy
and
um do you color your hair no
okay well there you go uh that that when
you start getting white grain silver
hair that's not aging it's a red warning
light that you're
deficient in certain minerals there's so
many uh the minerals that prevents you
from getting uh white grain silver hair
also prevent aneurysms your aorta and
your pulmonary arteries and prevent
problems in the bowels in your heart and
so forth so it's in and your skin so
it's imperative that you do everything
here not just you know just going to a
chiropractor and getting some relief for
15 minutes or a couple hours or a day or
two um isn't solving the problem
well and i'm glad that you brought up
the chiropractor thing dr wallach
because i used to go to the chiropractor
a lot
in fact there were times where i would
be going in so
and hurting so bad
that i would get relief because things
would adjust but then stepping into my
car
i had to go back in for another
adjustment because i'd already lost my
adjustment
wow
and since starting on
in the beginning like i said was the pig
pack plus
which includes the tangy tangerine the
osteo effects the plant dried minerals
the glucogel the essential fatty acids
and extra plant derived minerals
once i started getting on that
i could go to the chiropractor
and
my my adjustments held
i would go weeks and
like
every once in a while my original
chiropractor jumps on and he and i know
he watches the replays he's like becca
okay i've watched your story count me in
um so i'm super excited about that and
that's just encouragement for all of you
that are watching if you
are
a chiropractor or you see a chiropractor
or you know people that are
chiropractors and they
are really in it to help the people
help them find relief not just have them
keep coming back
but adding a good quality
supplement program and i i've gone to
chiropractors that have had supplements
but before finding youngevity
those supplements
i didn't feel a difference
i didn't see a difference
and i invite you to feel and see
the difference
with what dr wallach has put together
with his formulas
so i started with
the young the
pig pack plus
and then i went into
the bona joint formula and
one thing that the bone and joint
formula has dr wallick that the pig pack
plus does not
is that cm cream
i mean that's a topical that i would put
on my neck i had five herniated discs
i had three in my neck and two in my
lumbar and i could put that on
my neck and on the lumbar
and i would have relief almost instantly
for a few hours
and
use that as my body was actually
regenerating and strengthening
all of that connective tissue
that then helped hold me in place in
fact
i talk too much but anyways um
no that's good information well
and see i was diagnosed with scoliosis
as a child and i have always been
self-conscious of my back
in 1800 they would have said that you
had rickets
well
that rickets or whatever you called it
you know created that that help in the
back and
and then falling and breaking my back i
got the curve you know oh just the whole
mess
that i thought i was going to have to
live with for the rest of my life
and since i've been able to strengthen
my core strengthen the muscles the
tendons everything that holds me up do
the exercises
use that inversion table
i'm able to stand up straighter
and i can wake up i can sleep through
the night without pain i can wake up
with no pain i can go through the day
with no pain
and it's just life-changing folks and if
you're living in pain right now
you know what i'm talking about
it's it's not something that you have to
deal with and we again invite you to
feel
the difference
because there's a huge difference
huge
and 45 50 years old thank you dr wallach
wallace
but
again everybody
you know this message is being put
together
because it's coming from our heart
there's too many people that are hurting
in this world all around the world
i get emails from them all the time
what do you what can i do for this what
can i do for this
you know
it it breaks my heart to see people
hurting without having to
so that that's why i host this program
and we've been going for over two years
now every single friday i think we
missed once because it fell on either
chris i think it was christmas eve we
didn't miss the new year's eve but we
missed we skipped the christmas eve so
people could spend time with their
families
the doctor walk i have like i said i
have so many emails and you know this
message today
is perfect
with some of the emails that i have
gotten
um because
chandra is writing in
and on behalf of her daughter who she
adopted at 18 months old her daughter is
only 23 years old dr wallach
she
has had a knee surgery at 16 that's the
age they wanted to do knee surgery on me
because i had calcium overgrowth on the
back sides of their of my kneecaps and
they wanted to go in there and scrape it
i'm like
i hurt but i i couldn't bring myself to
do that
she's uh five foot five
weighs 220 pounds
she's had three babies in four and a
half years
she suffers with anxiety depression
and she has since she was a preteen
um she has almost no ability to handle
stress and either freezes or lashes out
she's already had her gallbladder
removed last year due to gallstones
and
she went to the er a couple months ago
and they found that she has
cysts
um so dr wallach
all of these things and and i had cysts
i had i didn't have my gallbladder
removed but i had my appendix removed
i know now what it's called gluten alert
gluten alert
exactly and we very much
made our own bread we thought we were
doing the right thing
and
making sure that we had all those whole
grains well those whole grains were
causing harm
so dr wallach what would you recommend
for chandra's daughter
who's 23 5 foot 5 220 pounds
she's already had knee surgery
she's suffering from anxiety depression
um
stress
had her gallbladder removed all these
different things she's had cysts
okay well here we go
she needs to get rid of all the bad
foods no fried foods okay that means
that no air frying no deep frying no pan
frying no fried foods absolutely cheese
to get rid of
the um
oh let's see here not only the fried
foods but she also needs to get rid of
any of the foods that are uh
cooked in oils no oils okay no
cooking oils and no salad dressings no
that kind of stuff no processed meats no
bologna salami pastrami pepperoni no ham
no bacon because they all have chemicals
in them
and then she needs to stay away from
gluten no wheat nobody rhinos there are
no such things as gluten-free oats the
gluten in oats is called gliadin but
it's still gluten still causes damage
the intestines okay and when the
appendix goes out that means that your
body's already saying hey this is really
bad
and so i'm going to kill the appendix
here because there's too much damage you
know from the
from the gluten and so that's why people
have to have an appendicitis thing okay
now this gal is about 70 pounds
overweight
and she's got all kinds of problems
including you know she didn't say if she
had anemia or anything like that but she
does have
musculoskeletal
problems okay and she has cysts she
didn't say they're ovarian cysts or
whatever had her
gallbladder taken out
okay so i want her also to have
um and see here
um two
a minimum
of two healthy brain
and heart packs per month two healthy
brain heart patch month full dose
everything twice a day she needs the big
hammer she needs two bottles a month in
the msm so you can take three at
breakfast straight at lunch for dinner
time to support and promote mainstream
pair of cartilage ligaments tendons
connective tissue discs between the
vertebrae bone makes bone itself
she needs to take the ultimate enzymes
take two or three of those say five or
ten minutes for each meal a couple
ounces of water we call it the
gallbladder bottle because we do put
bile in there for we take the bile from
the gallbladders the cattle that are
killed in the
in the um
slaughterhouse we dry it and put them in
our ultimate enzyme they think we're one
of the few
enzyme products out there in the market
that has bile in it so we call it the
gallbladder in a bottle anybody who's
had a gallbladder
removed or has gallbladder problems or
gallstones need to be on our ultimate
enzymes because of that bile okay
and then
also i said msm's okay she also needs
the uh let's see here the collagen
peptides i'll scoop with that with her
morning drink let's go with her evening
drink and to lose that 75 pounds
i want her to
take our keto shake you know this is not
to be added to a meal this is a meal
replacer it doesn't have to be the same
meal every day one meal a day
and
she will lose a half a pound of two
pounds a day and so she'll lose that
weight over a period of three to four
months
and as long as she stays on the program
she'll never gain that weight back
okay because when you gain weight
because you have a behavior called pica
which is your body's response to being
deficient in certain minerals your
body's looking for that mineral so you
eat more food you eat more food you eat
more foods i don't know why i'm gaining
all this weight
okay well that's because people have
pica p-i-c-a you can look it up in any
dictionary
insatiable desire to eat
and that's why people become obese you
get them on the nutrition program you
get them off those bad foods maximize
absorption get rid of the gluten and all
that kind of stuff and it all comes
right and you'll lose half a pound two
pounds
a day
so i think we covered most of her
problems uh so let's start there we do
need to hear from her every couple of
weeks and we can walk her through this
but don't forget that keto
shake is a meal replacer it's not an
add-on one meal a day
that's right and it tastes good too and
you don't have to mix it in a whole lot
of water i like to mix it in just about
eight ounces of water and if you're
truly doing a ketogenic diet and you're
looking for your macros you can put in a
tablespoon of heavy cream it can be
dairy
cream it can be coconut cream just to
help you keep those macros and it's very
satisfying i absolutely love it so dr
willick thank you so much for that
and debbie is writing in and she says
i'm 69 years old
115 pounds
at five foot one
so she's 69 115 pounds five foot one
and
her issue
is
i have a rib that pops out about once a
year it's been happening for 25 years
at first i thought it was a pinched
nerve and then last year when it
happened i went to the chiropractor he
told me that it was not pinched nerve
that he had i had a rib out
um he put it back in but it happened
again
the other day and
he had to put it back in so she said
when if
the rib pops out it feels like knife
stabbing her
and it just doesn't let look up let up
and i remember those moments
where the ribs were pop out and it's
because of what we just talked about
that connective tissue and not
holding everything together
that is correct that is correct of
course you notice as she got older it
keeps popping out
more and more frequently because the
damage is continuing to
manifest itself getting worse and worse
and worse worse because she's just been
getting
sort of symptomatic relief with the
chiropractic and massage
and maybe aspirin and that kind of stuff
and so she's really not
giving the body what it needs to repair
itself
so
at 115 pounds she's getting rid of all
the bad foods no fried foods no
processed meats no oils no glutens and
wheat no barley round nose no sugar no
carbon or drinks even the diet one's got
to go
and then i'd have her take um i'd give
her the big hammer here because she's
got a real problem which could
be devastating okay and so i would say a
one healthy branded heart pack per month
uh get another bottle of our selenium
with the five cofactors in it not from
walgreens and i wanted to have three of
our slam twice a day for those cofactors
which are going to help you know rebuild
the cartilage and the ligaments and
tendons and connective tissue i want her
to have
um
a half a dose of everything in that
healthy brain and heart pack
twice a day
i want her to
also have
the um let's see here the msm
one bottle a month or the msm so you can
take six a day two at breakfast two at
lunch with dinner time and they're gonna
help her support and promote mainstream
pair of cartilage ligaments tendons
connective tissue discs between a
vertebrae bone makes bone itself and all
the rib attachments and everything then
she also needs
the um collagen peptides a scoop of that
in her morning drink a scoop of that her
evening drink and then she also needs
the
uh beyond osteo fx that hair take
serving that twice a day and it could be
pills capsules or
powder or liquid because it comes in all
forms
but um two two servings a day
okay of the beyond osteo fx
and then
also i wanted to have vitamin d3 take
three of those twice a day there's two
bottles a month so she can absorb these
minerals and put them in the proper
places
and she should see
some very very good response within two
to six weeks now i say give us 90 days
because in 90 days you're going to be
very very happy when you have bone and
joint problems
they have the capacity to heal when they
have the raw materials given to them
if you're just giving them pain relief
they'll give you pain relief for a few
moments you're just giving mechanical
relief
you might not get pain relief for longer
than just a few minutes because it'll
pop right back out especially as time
goes on
because the damage continues to get
worse and worse and worse and worse but
these things are totally resolvable
um and so
and you might even get your chiropractor
or a massage therapist involved because
he'll see the benefits you're getting
and you'd want to
um do that with his other patients or
her other patients right and so that way
you can actually build a little business
and um you pay wholesale prices for the
products uh you get an auto ship i will
pay the shipping so you save a lot of
money
yeah you definitely can save money with
with the auto ship
um and
you know be honest with you dr wallach
the shipping costs that youngevity
offers
are not out of line i tried shipping a
bottle of plant derived minerals the
other day okay our plant drive minerals
are only like 26 bucks for a full bottle
for that 26 dollar bottle of plant
derived minerals the post office was
charging me 18 to ship it
18 bucks and i can ship it directly from
youngevity for eight dollars and fifty
cents
that's a ten dollar savings right there
so when i have people say oh your
shipping is horrible i'm like um no try
shipping it yourself then you'll get
some perspective
but it's it's amazing dr wallach how
when you really get the big picture
okay and that we're talking about the
big picture of health right now
what are you willing to invest in your
own health
are you
wanting to stay where you're at or
continue decline
by investing in all these fast foods and
convenience foods and foods that are
just full of fillers and no nutrients
or are you willing to take a look at
your diet and start investing in actual
nutrition
it's like i said earlier we're using
food as nutrition in our products
things that are actually going to be
benefiting the body
and
giving those cells the raw ingredients
that they need
to be able to do their jobs as our body
was designed
now
like i said in disclaimer we're not here
to treat cure any of those things
with our products but your body can do
amazing things
absolutely incredible how we were
divinely created
now
dr wellick i've got a couple um emails
here more than a couple
sure okay let's go for it we've got
about 20 minutes before the top of the
hour
um and
jared
jeremiah
or is it jermaine might be germaine
excuse me he says his mom has asthma
she says that has that covet has really
bothered it
so she's having a harder time breathing
and unfortunately he doesn't give weight
or anything like that but i know that
there's a lot of people that are have
breathing issues prior to
having effects of what's going on in the
last two years
that's kind of intensified their
breathing
so dr wallach share with us a little bit
about what we can do for ourselves to
help improve lung function
okay well asthma is actually a simple
nutritional deficiency it's it's not
anything autoimmune your body's not
attacking itself you don't have a
genetic problem well everybody in our
family's got the ansible that's because
they're eating the same way and living
in the same place
and they're not they're avoiding the
same thing okay
and so
per 100 pounds of body weight you want
to get rid of all the bad stuff no fried
foods no processed meats no oils no
glutens no wheat no bar right now so
sugar no carbonated drinks even the diet
one's got to go because it's the
carbonation and diet drinks um
neutralize your stomach acid so you
cannot efficiently absorb minerals and
and actually um
digest food okay
so you do need to do all this stuff
okay to make sure you can absorb the
nutrients and then
uh per 100 pounds of body weight because
asthma can turn into a fatal thing so
you really really have to watch it and
so i would um add
okay to their their meal
um the healthy branded heart pack one
per hundred pounds of body weight if
they weigh 150 pounds i'd go for two
healthy brain hard packs
take a full
dose of twice a day
and
get all the raw materials that are
necessary
including the ones necessary to prevent
and reverse asthma asthma is a very
simple nutritional deficiency when you
have little kids that are
six months old 10 months old
two years old and they have asthma
they're getting cortisone
shots everything they're getting kind of
a clinical relief
but the underlying nutritional
deficiency is getting worse and worse
and worse and worse they're going to
have some
um which they say they're going to have
some disaster later on down the line
and so i really really urge them
to
take the
for these kids we have the kids toddy
you know kids under
uh three four five years of age you can
take the kids today and the efas
take the kids toddy and the efas the
dosage for the kids toddy's on the back
it tastes like cherries it's the liquid
comes in quartz
uh and so follow the dosage um program
on on the back of the label
and then of course the efas you want to
take um uh one efa and one efa plus
a day okay save for
a newborn baby even if the baby's
getting breastfed if the mother is
eating gluten and she can't absorb the
nutrients that's still not coming
through the breast milk so the baby
who's being breastfed also needs to have
at least one serving a day of the kids
toddy and also the efas
and as they get a little older they want
to take the
um they can take if they want the liquid
they can take the cherrymans if they
want to take the mineral sticks okay
they can take the mineral sticks
with the collagen in it and so there's
all kinds of ways to get this nutrition
into kids
okay they're having asthma asthma can go
away in weeks
we've had it for five six eight ten
years and in two to four weeks it's gone
because it's a very simple nutritional
deficiency and of course uh doctors keep
telling people it's autoimmune you know
it's one of those things you just gotta
learn how to live with and take your
cortisone protozoan and uh you know see
we can reduce all that inflammation and
blah blah blah blah
and i don't know if they just don't know
they're not taught properly in medical
school or what the deal is but but
asthma is a simple nutritional
deficiency disease
um dr wallach i used to carry one of
those inhalers because i had asthma
um i have not used an inhaler in
seven years
nor have i had the need to
or thinking where's my inhaler because i
remember anytime i would go out for a
walk
one of the first things i did was check
to make sure i have my phone and my
inhaler
that's pretty sad
rather than just put my shoes on and go
for a run
i had to make sure that i had my
emergency stuff
just in case
so i love the fact that i don't even
have to it's not even a thought anymore
and i had 12 years where i raised my
stepdaughter where we were doing
nebulizer treatments
i wish i knew this information back then
she would have issues with
her lungs um it wasn't they didn't ever
say it was cystic fibrosis
but damage caused by
being on a machine right at birth
called an ecmo machine
and she had a nice little scar right
here where they took
pulled the blood out
oxygenated it warmed it put it back in
her tiny little body
and she
continued to have lung issues
and all she needed was the 90 including
the efas like i said i wish i would have
known then what i know now
could have saved us a lot of issues
so
folks
when i was taking her
to her appointments those rooms were
full
of mamas and their babies that were
having lung issues
if you know somebody
that has a child that has any type of
lung or breathing issues
share this information with them
you can find the replay of this program
on our website
askdoclive.com
so we invite you
to check that out we have every single
replay except for the one that we didn't
have
posted on that website for you to be
able to watch and learn and write down
and share information
that is empowering
for yourself your families and your
communities
so
it's just another thing it's like man
you know life at one time
really sucked dr wallach
i'm gonna be real here
i didn't look forward to getting old i i
was fearful of my children and
if they
were for my daughter
was she going to make it through the
night
because there were nights where we were
doing nebulizer treatments in the middle
of the night
oh my
and sometimes multiple
and now with the information that i know
and with some of the kiddos that we've
already helped
i know that there's more options but
those options are not being shared
in a doctor's office
right now we're in your office we're in
my office and folks we
invite you to hear this message and not
just hear it
not just listen but share it
and that's what stock live is all about
and and we don't charge them anything
for our information and you know our
time
and they pay wholesale prices for the
product and if they get on auto ship we
pay the shipping
there you go
there's there's a lot of benefits dr
wallach to the program that you have put
together
that
the only thing
that somebody is having to pay for
is what they're putting in their body to
make their bodies stronger
the advice is free the recommendations
is free
we do have some health coaches and in
fact i do have clients of myself that
yes i do charge for my services
is my time is valuable too
but the biggest part is making sure
people are getting this information so
that they can help themselves
in creating a brighter future for
themselves and look forward to
getting older
well dr wallach i have another and for
those of you who are on with us if you
have questions
please feel free to raise your hand go
to that zoom menu
find the reactions
option click raise hand i know last week
when i mentioned it again i had six
hands go right up
so we have a full room and i know
everybody i'm looking at the cameras and
everybody's frantically taking notes
well
raise your hand if you have questions i
know that you have
if it's for yourself or somebody that
you know and care about
um we are here to make sure that you get
the information
that is needed to be able to make
differences in the lives of yourself and
others
now the next email that i have dr
welling
let me get to the right page here
forgive me
okay
so
corey is writing in and corey is 63 year
old female
5 foot 3
135 pounds
and she starts out that i do not wake up
during the night to urinate
now that's a common question that you
have that so many people
um we find
it's it's real folks
having to get up during the night just
because you roll and then you have to go
to the bathroom
well there's a reason for that
she does say i do smoke half a pack of
cigarettes a day but no alcohol
she was first diagnosed with major
depression and attention deficit
disorder in 1994
and she was put on a very common
prescription for
the ad
d and then another one for depression um
she says i've been experiencing sleep
problems for about 10 years after my
son's suicide
i can't imagine my heart goes out to you
mama
i'm unable to fall asleep until around 3
4 a.m and then sleep until 3 to 5 p.m
if no one wakes me there's a couple
hours of fog thereafter and it takes
time to clear before i can do anything
most nights i have bad dreams causing me
to cry and talk often
waking up my boyfriend
uh two years ago i was diagnosed with
ptsd
treated with emdr you might know what
that is
and within a few months the depression
was completely gone so she's very
thankful for that
unfortunately the depression was gone
but her sleeping problems were not
the symptom of the
depression
so she's wanting to know dr wallach
what can she do for her sleep issues
um
she says basically she's got some sort
of circadian rhythm disorder
um and she's she's wanting
to try something else because the things
that have been tried aren't working
so
yeah we're looking with depression we're
looking with add and we're looking with
sleep
and then
for some people half a pack of
cigarettes is quite a bit
well it's it's uh quite a bit for
anybody
okay
i'm saying right yeah the human beings
are not meant to smoke
okay so anyway um at 135 pounds i want
her to get rid of all the bad foods no
fried foods no processed meats no oils
no glutens no wheat no butter rhinos no
sugar no carbonated drinks even the diet
one's got to go
and then 135 pounds i want her to have
one healthy brain and heart pack per
month half a dozen everything twice a
day but i do want her to get another
bottle of our selenium with the five
cofactors in it so she could take three
of those twice a day because one bottle
will come with the health abandoned
heart pack i also want her to have the
de-stress
cap so she go ahead and take three of
those twice today i want her to get the
memory effects take three of those twice
today i want her to get our synaptic
synaptic is the biochemistry necessary
for the the neighboring brain cell to
talk to each other so they can all kind
of go the same direction
and this will help her with the
depression and anxiety and all this
other stuff i wanted to have three of
those twice today that's two bottles a
month that's synaptive
okay
and then
i wanted to have three eggs twice a day
with soft yolks
okay soft boiled soft yolks off some
i'll see here soft poached soft yolk
soft soft scrambling butter that's how i
have mine
okay
we had um some great uh scrambled eggs
uh yesterday we had the
kind of semi-soft boiled eggs for
breakfast this morning okay because she
could also and she needs to get a hold
of that book and the cd
it's all on your head because much of
what she's talking about has to do with
osteoporosis of the skull
okay squeezing the spinal cord squeezing
the 12 cranial nerves and having all
these various issues
osteoporosis of the skull and the eggs
she might also have ms she might have
diabetes syndrome so she needs to
you know maybe go visit somebody else a
different physician
and then ask do i have gmbra syndrome do
i have ms and they can do some scans and
things to see how much of her
brain has been impacted because 25 of
your brain weight is cholesterol and if
people get on
their ego if people
get on
a cholesterol-reduced diet and they take
satin drugs that lower their cholesterol
because their doctor
incorrectly believes that cholesterol
causes plaque in the arteries
that's why we have so many problems um
alzheimer's disease at the rate we have
it now and and
things like
ms and gamboray syndrome at the rate we
have it now never occurred before until
1960.
okay when they came out with statin
drugs and people were told don't eat
cholesterol don't eat eggs
25 of the normal brain weight is
cholesterol your brain cells make
cholesterol many many body cells make
cholesterol this is an essential
nutrient and doctors are giving a lot of
people misinformation by saying stay
away from cholesterol
and so go that direction
and um i would also have her take the
ultimate daily classic tablets three of
those twice a day as two vowels a month
so she get proper blood flow into the
brain
um
and to the coronary arteries in the
heart into the kidneys and so forth
and she can you know go to a pharmacy
without a prescription get some test
strips to check her blood sugar or sugar
in her urine
she can
uh you know
you know get those kind of test strips
and find that kind of stuff out herself
okay and so we do want to hear from her
because she's going to have a great
story because all of her
um
uh
issues including the ptsd the
post-traumatic stress disorder all that
kind of stuff
okay bad dreams
sleep issues these are all nutritional
deficiencies
okay and just taking prednisone and
cortisone and
sleeping pills doesn't cover it
might relieve some of the symptoms but
it doesn't
deal with the cause of the issue
okay back to you
all right thank you dr wallach and hey
we're close enough to the top of the
hour folks let's go ahead and take a
five minute break get up and stretch
make sure that you have plenty of fluids
do not there is absolutely no reason to
become dehydrated
at all
here in
or wherever you are around the world and
you can become dehydrated whether it's
hot whether it's cold it does not matter
and when your body starts to become
dehydrated
every organ is affected so make sure
that you are not becoming dehydrated and
i love the fact that no matter what i
put in my drink i can put plant-derived
minerals in it
and make sure that i am continually
giving my body
the currency of life because
minerals are the currency of life folks
to have a healthy life we have to
replenish what our food no longer has
for us we will be right back on ask doc
live don't go away
i am back with ask doc live
and we just welcome you and thank you
for joining us here each each and every
friday or any day of the week any hour
of the day
on askdoc live for those
of you who are on here as you're with us
we know that you are truth seekers you
are
sponges absorbing information
that
you can use to help yourself and help
your families and help your communities
since we're like when you're like a
sponge you're soaking up all this
information and then when the need
arises all you have to do is squeeze
just a little bit plant that seed water
that seed
and
you will watch
and be able to see
yourself your family and your community
just start to bloom
and come more alive with less pain
personal experience and folks if i
hadn't experienced it myself i wouldn't
have believed it
and i cannot keep this information to
myself so i am so honored to be able to
be your host again my name is rebecca
dukes kozak and i have an amazing group
of co-hosts that are on with me that
help me each and every week make sure
that we get information in the chat so
if you're on live with us
use that chat if you're watching the
replay
on our website or on youtube or on
rumble or bitshoot wherever you're
tuning in from
we have the ability there where you can
make comments on that video and one of
our certified holistic health coaches
will be able to get with you and answer
those questions
based on
dr wallock's
teachings
so dr wallach go ahead and unmute
yourself
with dr wallach's teachings they're not
just coming from a book that somebody
else wrote
dr wallach has done the research
he has read a lot of books
but he's also taking his own research
his autopsies which dr walik i want to
talk about that a little bit you shared
something with me the other day that
really touched me
that i want to share with with everybody
in regards to
when you have somebody on that table
for an autopsy
how how is that
what is that experience like
well it's a very intimate situation
because you're really literally
literally dealing
with them
they're inside and outside
and so
um
i like to think that when i'm doing
autopsy on somebody i want to be their
best friend
i'm looking to help them
when i
um take their kidneys out and look at
them
i'm looking at their kidneys to see how
i could have helped them
why did they die and so forth and so
it's really a very intimate thing of
course
the first major
thing that i did um
uh was
um i was actually a
third year veterinary student at the
university of missouri in columbia
missouri and it was christmas time and
all the all the um
various
teachers and professors were out on
christmas
and i was working in the pathology
department to pay for my tuition in
veterinary school because i'm just a
poor dumb farm boy
and so i'm still doing some of those
autopsies of animals um
when all these professors were going for
the christmas holiday
well this one day at 19
um
during christmas holiday
uh this farmer came by and dumped
um
uh 50 dead lambs on me
and just you know he told me he
the night before
yesterday the day before um
he had 500 lambs they're beautiful uh he
fed them in the evening they're all
jumping in and out of the
uh of the
um
the
the facilities that had you know the
food put in there and they're
laying around rolling in all the food
and they're making noise and chasing
each other and all happy 500.
well the next morning you know we're
talking 12 hours later he wakes up to go
feed him in the morning they're all dead
500 head died in one night and so he
brought me 50 of them
and
it turns out to make a long story short
i found out that the neighbors have been
fertilizing their their feed
for many years was nitrates and the
nitrates have been slowly washing into
the pond where these lambs have been
getting their
water
okay
and
the night that they all died the
temperature dropped from in the mid 50s
down to 16.
okay they died of hypothermia because
they were getting so much nitrates in
their food they couldn't handle the
temperature change
and so i wrote it up and so when the
professors all came back in a week i
said well i've written up a basic
program here of what happened the story
that the farmer gave me and here's all
the data
and um i believe this is due to a
pollution problem blah blah blah and i
had all the chemistries and so they
agreed and so can i be a co-author or
something or can you mention me and they
say you're crazy well we weren't even
here so this is your baby that was my
first scientific publication
and i it got published in 1965 a year
after i graduated i was getting on
airplanes you know to go to africa and
work on the white rhino conservation
project which resulted in the rhino
express book
and that was my first book rhino express
and of course my first publication uh
scientific publication as far as a
like a
research project
was on this mass dial from pollution
and again to make a long story short i
was in africa working for marlon perkins
the old mutual mahal kingdom show
uh to save the white rhino
and
two years into it he calls me back
because he got a big grant to find out
what the heck was happening here
because
there were so many things going on in
the united states
and
he said this might be some of your
pollution stuff that you've been talking
about wallach
okay it was a
25 million
um 25 million dollar
grant from nih national institutes of
health to washington university in st
louis missouri uh barry commenter was
the head of the department of biology
there and marlon perkins and i had
worked together
in the
tv thing um
okay
uh with all the african animals and so
forth and so
this was kind of everything coming
together in one place
and so i got to be the pathologist on
the project because i'm the one that
figured out that was those mass die off
those 500 sheep were due to a pollution
problem and what they wanted to do is
find out
what species of animals would die from
the same pollutants that humans would
and they wanted to use these animals in
cities in big zoos just like the coal
miners used to take canaries down in the
mine and the gases would leak into the
mine the canaries would die and the men
knew to get out so if these animals
started dying
from pollution in the big cities the
people knew to evacuate cities so that
was the whole idea of the grant
and um
it was crazy the things that i learned
i learned that the nutritional
deficiencies were the big problems
nutritional deficiencies was a big
problem because in the zoos the animals
were being fed human food
and so
and they were getting some supplements
they get trace metal salt blocks the
animals could run up and lick it and get
a few minerals and things like that but
it wasn't really
aggressively proactive to get all 90
essential nutrients and so that's that's
my story
okay
um how i got involved in this diabetes
thing and there's 37.3 million cases of
diabetes each year in the united states
okay
that's 11.3
of our population there's 96 million
pre-diabetics in the united states 96
million about a third of our population
okay because our population is 332
million 228 thousand 200 so just short
of a third of our population are
pre-diabetics holy moly and the annual
cost
of just treating the symptoms of
diabetes
not preventing it not curing it but just
treating the symptoms each year in
america is 342 billion
one-third of a trillion 342 billion
holy moly okay so if somebody has
diabetes and arthritis
you know we're talking big problem here
because for arthritis we're spending
626.8 billion dollars a year just to
treat the symptoms and for diabetes
we're spending 342 billion in case we're
right at a trillion dollars between the
two of those
okay
and so it's very very scary um and so
um that's why
um i was able to get these awards i'm
very very proud of that
and so now it's time to move on and get
more and more information out there so
we can save more people and we just
can't thank you enough for letting me be
on ask dr like
thank you dr wellick and so i want to go
back real quick to nitrates
okay
nitrates affected
those lambs bodies ability to maintain
their temperature their core temperature
which then caused them to die of
hypothermia that's correct the first
thing that comes to my mind when you say
nitrates
is all of the processed meats
right let's always say no
process
olive oil salami
yeah and it's so
prevalent in the stores i mean
the lunch meat
cold case
is bigger than the milk case
and then we wonder why people are having
issues with their thyroid
these things that are being called
autoimmune diseases
that link to
the thyroid
you found
one of the very first cases
in the animal world which then directly
transfers over because folks we're
animals too okay
we're not going to get out of that we're
mammals we're animals
um that
our bodies are affected the same
nitrates things that are approved to be
put into food
and yes my new amounts
might be required
kind of like that thing that we all
panic when we see arsenic
trace amounts of arsenic the body
requires
but
intentionally putting it into our bodies
and something that we think is food
and healthy because it's a meat no
let's look at our diets folks and go
with those whole meats start cooking
more at home
let's get out of the rat race
of always having to be in a hurry and
always picking the things that are quick
and easy
well planning
helps us make things
easier
so that we can then get away from these
chemicals that are negatively harming
our bodies
i'm off my soapbox now let's go to the
hand that's uh dr wallach
okay let's go to some callers all right
so theresa
ortho terese
go ahead and unmute yourself you are on
live with dr wallach if you want to come
on camera that would be fabulous also
hi how are you it's therese by the way
teresa thank you yeah
two-part question what i think are
simple questions so i'm 49 when i was
seven years old i had gillian beret
um
i have no which is it which is ms which
is a cholesterol deficiency
okay
really
um so my question to you is i'm 49 i
have no other symptoms i mean yes i've
had asthma all my life i have had issues
with some
sensitivities and allergies but my
question is do i have anything as an
adult to worry about that i need to
keep an eye on because of having gillian
brey as a child
okay well let me back up a little bit
here how much do you weigh
140 and how tall are you
five one
okay do you have any other issues any
simple issues like arthritis or back
problems high blood pressure diabetes
no i do have um this is where the other
part of the question comes into you i
was also told i have turf toe
i'm sure
they called it turf t-u-r-f toe has
something to do with the muscles or the
ligaments in my to in my foot
i don't really know what that is that's
why i was asking about that as well
okay
all right do you have any ring in your
ears any tinnitus or ringing in your
ears yes
okay how long ahead tonight is
as long as i can remember i've always
had some type of ringing okay do you
have any balance problems any vertigo
dizziness
okay i have where to go
okay
all right
um yeah you have osteoporosis to the
skull
okay is your main problem have
osteoporosis of the skull uh the
tinnitus the ring in the ear is the
skull squeezing the auditory branch of
the atrial nerve the dizziness or
vertigo is caused by your skull
squeezing the vestibular branch through
the atrial nerve
all right
uh do you have anything going on with
your thyroid gland or metabolism or
anything like that
not that i'm aware of okay do you have
any skin problems any eczema dermatitis
or psoriasis
no
okay good
but you do have asthma oh okay it's okay
so asthma
uh this toe thing could be due to the
skull squeezing the spinal cord as the
spinal cord is made in the skull then
comes out to the back and runs down the
back but the skull when you have
obviously approached the skull instead
of being a quarter of an inch thick like
a skull is supposed to be in human
beings it gets to be an inch or two
inches thick and all the holes and
tunnels that the spinal cord and the
nerves are coming through
the inside diameter is reduced by maybe
50 to 75 putting a lot of pressure on
those nerves that's why you have all
these symptoms
and so if you can say you had tinnitus
ringing in the ears as long as you
remember you could have been born with
osteoporosis of the skull because it's
not an age thing
and it's a nutritional deficiency thing
and you can have obviously your people
it's called herbs palsy
when kids are born with osteoporosis as
a skull herb's palsy
so here we go
at 140 pounds
i want you to um get rid of all the bad
foods no fried foods no processed meats
no oils no glutens no wheat no butter i
know so sugar no carb inner drinks
okay um
they all have to go even the diet ones
and then i want you to take two healthy
brain and heart pasture months you're
right on that cusp so let's since you've
had this for a long time let's just say
let's go with two healthy brain heart
packs per month photo setting twice a
day
i want you to get um two miles a month
for msm so you can take three at
breakfast three at lunch dinner time and
they're going to help support and
promote managed repair of cartilage
ligaments tendons connective tissue
discs between the vertebrae bone ranks
bone itself including the skull and you
really need to get a hold of that book
in that cd that rebecca and i did
together
it's all in your head this is really
going to help you
um the information
and then um
i need you also
uh because the asthma i want you to get
some extra of the efpas
okay i want you to take there'll be efas
in the healthy brand heart pack i want
you to get another bottle of the efas so
you can take it three times a day
instead of twice a day
okay
and
as long as you're staying away from the
gluten the bad foods no wheat powder i
know she'll absorb this stuff
i'm actually actually i'm actually
allergic to wheat so i don't eat any
gluten any wheat any products like that
at all
okay good excellent excellent
excellent
and then we have oxybody which is a
liquid uh mineral thing which has oxygen
in it so you could take you know a dose
of that half ounce twice a day maybe one
quart a month of the oxy body
um that's going to help you
um
let's see the toe thing
but by by dealing with the osteoporosis
of the skull that toe thing should
resolve itself
okay because your skull is squeezing
your spinal cord you're getting all this
stuff going on south down into your toes
we call hammer toe turf toe hammer toe
um kind of thing
and uh it's caused by the skull
squeezing the spinal cord
okay and then uh you do have ms are
our um
the the kids version of that ms multiple
sclerosis
okay
um
and uh
let's start there now don't forget you
need three eggs twice a day to rebuild
the myelin in your brain
okay you need three eggs twice a day
that'll be a soft ball with soft yolks
soft close to soft yolks uh soft soft
boiled with soft yolks i have mine i
love the yolks as soft as i can get them
i want my to be able to pour my eggs
okay like like soup
okay so you really need the yolk sauce
to get that cholesterol when people
get examined for ms and gamma-ray
syndrome they actually do a scan
of the skull because 25 percent of the
normal brain weight is cholesterol what
25 percent of your normal brain weight
25 of your normal brain weight of
is cholesterol
okay
and when you start losing your
cholesterol you start getting ms and
guillain-barre syndrome is is ms in kids
underneath the age of 25.
all right well nobody's ever told me no
one has ever ever said that so thank you
for enlightening me
okay well most doctors don't get taught
anything about osteoporosis skull and if
you ask them what causes guillain-barre
syndrome what causes ms they will say oh
it's an autoimmune disease your body's
attacking itself
okay that's because they don't know and
so they blame it on you so they don't
have to say i don't know
but all the details are in that book in
the cd it's all in your head
okay
it'll blow your mind and that that book
and cd are flying literally flying off
the shelf
um
and so that's because people have been
seeking the answers to these questions
and doctors have been able to never been
able to do that
yeah and they say well ms you know
that's one of those things
where it's an autoimmune disease your
body's attacking itself there's nothing
to do about it except treats the
symptoms well it's nonsense because it's
a very simple nutritional deficiency
disease don't forget those three eggs
twice a day
and you can throw in the um
don't forget the msm don't forget the
collagen peptides
um it wouldn't hurt to throw in the
synaptis so the brain cells can talk to
each other
and the oxy body i love the oxy body for
people who have asthma okay
okay thank you so so much for all this
okay would you keep in touch with us you
know it's toll-free so give us a call
every couple of weeks and tell us you
know how things are going along
i will be happy to absolutely
okay thank you so much terese
bye-bye bye-bye thank you therese and
you mentioned the book dr wallach and
mr madera says that he went to amazon
and it shows that it's out on amazon
well folks we are not out
on wellness publications so if you go to
drjwalic.com
you will find
all of dr wallach's publications i know
on our website
askdoc live we do have links to his most
common publications um but some of those
are showing that they're out too that
just goes to prove that amazon's not
keeping up and well not only that i
would like to know i would like to know
if they stopped shipping that book
because the medical system is attacking
them no no no
we're not going to go there dr we're
spreading hope we're spreading the
positive and we're going to keep it that
way as we continue on and share
information with everybody so if you are
looking for the book and you're not able
to find it on amazon or askdoc live go
to drjwalic.com
i know over the last two days dr wallach
over
close to
copies of the it's all in your head and
cd have gone out their doors
so oh yeah that's very encouraging more
and more people are wanting this
information
in order to take their health into their
own hands
yeah it's a very common disease
scenario and
the medical system has missed it for so
many years treating symptoms
not getting down to the basic root cause
because they believe that it was due to
an autoimmune thing your body is
attacking itself no no no
yeah no no no and dr wallick um
i get so many emails and i just want to
thank heather because she helps me
monitor one of my email accounts and
this is one that really needs to be
shared
she says oh and this is miss w that's
what that's how she signed it
she says i'm writing to let dr wallach
know
how much i appreciate his expertise i
just
had to finally get this out there
my 85 year old mother was diagnosed with
stage 2b lung cancer december of 2021
hopefully or thankfully she only needed
surgery to remove a tumor instead of
radiation and chemo i had taken her some
of your supplements specifically the
bone and joint pack along with plant
derived minerals
this was to help strengthen her for the
recovery after surgery
doctors and physical therapists were
amazed that at 85 years old
she bounced back so quickly after a
grueling surgery and her tradition her
transition has been smooth selling
my sister and i bought her a tub chair
to help her get in and out of the tub
about a month or so later i saw that the
chair was gone and was now being used
for her tub accessories i asked her what
happened and why isn't she using the
chair anymore she says i don't need it i
can get in and out of the tub just fine
without any assistance
i can see that she is moving faster now
and she doesn't look as frail just
thriving at 85 years old and she's
loving life
miss w says i really truly believe that
your supplements have helped my mama get
back on her feet and going as strong as
she is your supplements are definitely
helping for the long haul for sure thank
you a hundred times
over your wisdom
knowledge and certainly its power
god bless you
what a moving story isn't it isn't it
beautiful yeah that gives me chills so
thank you heather for
for letting me know that that was there
and putting it to the top so i could
easily see it
um that is just absolutely fabulous
let's go to the next hand that is up dr
wallach
and john go ahead and unmute yourself if
you would like to come on camera you are
more than welcome to do so
dr wallach top of the morning to you yes
sir how can we help you out
yes i um
last week rebecca presented some of the
questions to you and it was regarding my
hip and then i was using the pain
to
to monitor the the progress of the hip
i wanted to let you know that you told
me basically to allow
90 days
for for certain things to improve
i wanted to let you know that that has
improved quite a bit
i
don't take pain medicine because i want
to feel the pain in order to know
how the improvement is that's taking
place
and um
and you also told me
i'm sorry
no go ahead you also told me to
to to go through and um
analyze all my other issues
you know it's not just the hip
that um i should be looking at i should
be looking at um
um matter of fact i'll tell you a couple
of the things that i've that i noticed
um
okay
basically i had a neck injury in in 1983
and uh the um they told me after a
period of time it would i would start
losing mobility and i did
where the neck i couldn't um
i couldn't
turn it as much that has changed i've
got a lot more mobility i was having
that that um issue where like bone on
bone it'd be like a scraping
and that's that's went away
and uh one thing that's interesting i've
noticed i've got more saliva
and i
i
basically have been aware that because
uh
at night i would um
when i exhale the breath would stop
but i believe that was due to uh
the uh
i guess it's your epiglottis um yeah
well how many times how many times at
night were you waking up to go to
urinate
uh you know i haven't had that issue as
far as urination never had never had
that issue okay good it could be once
you know and then go right back to bed
but what i have noticed is i'm getting
about one or two hours more sleep and
i've noticed this recently
and um
but i basically you you ask that i come
on and you know whenever i've got enough
information of improvement
i am optimal uh using the product um
just to
give you an idea i'm
i started out about
285 pounds i've i've dropped about five
pounds i am taking um
um the product that would be for um
rated for like 300 pounds
okay so you're taking the keto shake
yes i am
okay it's not one meal a day and it's
just a meal replacer don't add it to a
meal it's a meal replacer correct
i've also got the rebound okay like i
said i've taken optimum um
what what my account with the counselor
at youngevity has recommended
and like i said i what i wanted to bring
out too is that
um
the product is so valuable
people need to realize that
if they go in this fashion they're
getting better health and better
um
as far as than most people i mean
they're doctors anybody i mean people
you know your celebrities everybody you
can you can you can become a healthier
than they are
and it's not expensive the way i look at
that if i couldn't afford it
i would tell my sisters
i would tell um you know my cousin i say
look help me you know help me to get a
better health i said i you know the only
thing is i would then be uh obligated to
report to them how that my health was
doing so all i'm saying is
um people can it can be done
very easily
as far as that you're you know taking
the product and i intend on uh
continuing like i said i know that it's
um
you know the value is um you tell us
they take the minerals because you know
what your body needs it'll it'll use and
what it does it don't throw off
and um anyway i just want to tell you
i'm not going to compliment you i'm just
going to appreciate you okay thank you
so much and we appreciate you sharing
your story because it's a it's a very
very good story uh we see literally
thousands a day all over the world we're
in 80 countries and so thank you for
sharing your story god bless
john if i may ask
and this is to give hope for for others
that are listening
yes will you share your age
oh of course uh yes my age is i'm 68
and i guess i weigh uh
um
180 pounds now go ahead but you're
fairly tall as well right i'm 6'3 yes
yeah
so it doesn't matter how young or how
old you are when you get the right stuff
going into your body you're going to
have improvements
oh definitely definitely and it's
and we need to
we need to appreciate ourselves and be
selfish enough to take care of ourselves
all right very well said that's right
thank you so much john we appreciate you
coming on and checking in with us
you got it have a good day thank you
dr wellington let's go to the next hand
that is up and lawrence go ahead and
unmute yourself
there you go
you are on live with dr wallach
hi doc hi rebecca hello
i have a quick question for my son who
injured himself playing basketball
on tuesday night he heard a pop in his
left knee
and he went and got
x-rays
nothing's broken
but it's huge it swelled up really
really badly
and since then i put him on like
pineapple turmeric the swelling's gone
down but it's still throbbing the pain
how much does he weigh
he weighs
165 to 170.
okay
33 years old
okay does he have any other issues how
would pressure diabetes
no nothing he's uh basically an athlete
mm-hmm okay well athletes get problems
yes they do
okay is six one
okay 165 pounds and he has a knee issue
um i'd have them get off all the bad
foods no fried foods no processed meat
no oils or glutens no wheat bar right
now so sugar no carb drinks you know the
diet one's got to go
and have them take two healthy brain and
heart packs per month two healthy brain
hard passion month full dose everything
twice a day only get two bottles a month
of the msm so you can take three at
breakfast three at one street at a time
and they're gonna support and promote
maintenance repair of cartilage
ligaments tendons connective tissue disc
between the vertebrae bone makes bone
itself including in the knees and the
hips and the ankles and the shoulders
and elbows and fingers and toes and so
on
he also needs the collagen peptides the
scoop of that in his morning drink and
scoop that as evening drink it has
collagen from fish poultry sheep and
beef
and it helps to rebuild all the
connective tissue as well as the bone
marrow where you make your white blood
cells and red blood cells and platelets
and antibodies and so forth good for
immune system also
and then
excuse me it wouldn't hurt for him to
use something topically
uh on his um well one other thing excuse
me vitamin e3 should be taking vitamin
d3 two of our bottles of vitamin d3 so
we can take three of those twice a day
and then topically he can take our
uh cm cream
uh with the trauma oil in about five or
ten drops to the trum oil in a teaspoon
the same cream you can place on that
knee
and
[Music]
um
it'll be something that will work very
well
and just just remember uh
we're giving them a basic program he has
any other issues
we have what we call secret sauces for
600 different diseases so
you know you need to sit down and have a
mom and son talk
and
make sure he doesn't have any other
issues that have to be dealt with okay
but this will be a great start
the idea with literally thousands of
athletes uh we have so many of them
um
you know theo ratliff a great basketball
player 24 years old
uh he he had bone bone arthritis both
his knees
the cartilage popped off his hip he
fractured his shooting arm wrestling he
was
under contract with the
atlanta hawks they took away his
contract i came up with the rebound for
him
and the healthy morning joint pack for
and a year later he got a contract back
and he played for
11 years and made 100 million dollars in
that contract
by using just the
um
healthy bone and joint pack
and the rebound and his picture of steel
rattler's picture is on the cannon
rebounds on some of the canisters
uh in the box of this of the
sticks okay and such a great story
here's a nice young fella and of course
he's been very dutiful
he has bought some um
training of facilities
and he trains young athletes how to eat
properly and how to supplement properly
and how to take care of themselves to
maximize their performance and so he's
paying back by training all these young
athletes he didn't just take all the
money and run
so i was very proud of him okay
i do have one question if it's an if
it's an acl tear
with the healthy bone and
and the msm and the
collagen peptides and vitamin d will
that help that repair itself
okay well it depends is it a tear or is
it a complete avulsion i mean if if the
tendons and ligaments are just yanked
off the bone and they're just flapping
around on the breeze
uh it's not going to help that
but if it's just you know if you get a
few fibers torn or something like that
but it's still attached well yeah it
will definitely help enormously um but
then then you have you know five or six
different tendons holding on and say one
of them is torn
and the others are okay and so
the doctors when they did the
you know they didn't say okay we're
going to do a bunch of surgery and sew
everything back up and do they did they
suggest that
they all they did was an x-ray
and um
then they referred him out to see a
doctor
to get a what a mri
and he won't be able to get that until
after he sees the doctor and so i don't
know if it's torn or not but he did hear
a pop when he um
well is he able to walk or limp on this
thing or is the swelling going down or
um he said the swelling is not as bad
today it happened tuesday no okay
swelling is not as bad
but he's he's in a in a brace
okay well let's get him on this uh
program and let's see what happens in
two weeks and whatever and you know
when the suggest stuff
uh just say well you test me again let's
see where i'm at you know don't just let
them run on
information from three weeks earlier
because you improve every minute you're
on this program okay
okay all right perfect
okay lauren we look forward to hearing
from you all right thank you dr wallet
okay bye-bye all right thank you
now dr wallach
i've got a question that's coming in in
an email from alan
and alan says good morning i look
forward to advice for neuropathy pain in
my feet
i've been to a podiatrist and have had a
couple shots was told that the pain is
caused by high arches the pain is not
affecting my sleep or daily activities i
just don't want it to advance anymore
i'm 64 years old six foot two inches
tall 217 pounds
exercise regularly and otherwise good
health i have no prescription medication
and
am interested in
general wellness program as well okay i
apologize how how old
64 okay
okay
all right and so with that little bit of
history
okay
we want to do is
when you have neuropathy neuropathy
means
you have pain some place
which is caused
by something going on someplace else
and so if you look at what's going on
where you have the pain
you don't see much
because
what's happening is happening upstream
so to speak okay squeezing the nerves
and and so then the pain shows up
south
okay that's called a peripheral
neuropathy
so
um
to see here
64 years old uh he's writing that kind
of middle-aged thing
um six foot two 217 pounds that's about
right so i want him to have get rid of
all the bad foods no fried foods no
processed meats no oils no glutens no
wheat no brother i know so sugar no
carbohydrate drinks even the diet one's
got to go and then i want them to have
two healthy brain heart attacks for
months two healthy brain heart factor a
month photo shooting twice a day i want
him to have
um two bottles a month of the msm so you
can take three at breakfast street at
lunch dinner time and they're going to
support and promote maintenance repair
of cartilage ligaments tendons
connective tissue discs between the
vertebrae bone makes about itself you
know in all his knees and
ankles and
hips and back and neck and all over the
place okay
and
they also wanted to have the collagen
peptides to scoop with that with his
morning drink because it was evening
drink and that's also going to help
repair cartilage and ligaments and
tendons and connective tissue and bone
marrow so we can make white blood cells
and platelets and red blood cells and
antibodies to support his immune system
and then i also wanted to have vitamin d
three three of those twice it has two
vowels a month
i also
want him to have
let's see we've talked about all the
collagen stuff
um uh he can use our rebound sports
drink instead of soft drinks and what i
do if i use the cans which i do on a
regular basis i pop the top in the
evening
um put them in the refrigerator so they
off gas all night get rid of the
carbonation so when i drink it in the
morning there's no carbonation in there
i don't want the carbonation i want the
nutrients that are in the rebound and if
you don't want to mess around with that
we do have a canister with 36 servings
in it says powder with no carbonation
and then we do have the sticks 36 in a
box with no carbonation
and um so you know there's all kinds of
stuff we do have the mineral sticks
which have a cherry extract tastes like
cherries they have collagen in there you
can take a few of those in this pocket
and and pop those into a cup of tea or
something like that during the day
or in a glass of water and that will you
know give him some more minerals
and so it's a matter of giving the body
what it needs to repair itself and stay
away from all the bad stuff that causes
inflammation and and causes a negative
um uh loss of nutrients and so it
wouldn't hurt
and to you know get some of these books
and things um but let
him
read this stuff okay it's all in your
head he's at that age where if he has
osteoporosis the skull is going to be
showing up all over the place and he can
have pain in his legs and ankles and
knees and think that's where it's at but
it's actually could be happening in his
neck and his in his skull
okay so
um
and if you buy the book and the cd
together at one time you get a discount
okay because set
the uh selling your headset if you buy
both the cd and the book at the same
time you get a nice discount if you buy
them a week apart you don't get the
discount
and so now let's see here with that
wouldn't hurt
to get the book rare earthman cures
chapter 10 tells you how to collect here
how to
package it up where to ship it don't
forget to put the check in there because
the lab won't run the check you get two
you get two charts one chart is your
essential nutritional minerals and tells
you if you're absorbing it tells you
which ones are low and then and also you
get a second chart which tells you if
you have any
of these um
toxic minerals like lead and mercury and
and uranium and stuff like that
and so it's a very very useful
a test so you don't need a doctor's
permission to get it and uh if you're
if you're running your own young jimmy
business it's a tax deductible thing
okay because it's helping you run your
business by being healthy and so forth
and um
the book is certainly a tax deduction
because again it's going to help you
maximize the benefit of your information
to your customers or your associates
your business partners okay
all right thank you so much dr wallach
so i've had a few people
not a few
several handfuls of people that reach
out that are on dialysis
now
in
when we were talking a little bit ago
about autopsies and you had mentioned
you know looking into kidneys
share with us a little bit dr wallach
about some of the underlying causes of
dialysis what we can do to prevent we've
got about 15 minutes here
things that we can do to prevent i'm all
about prevention
it's so much easier and
more affordable to prevent something
than to treat it later yeah well that's
why we put all in the car to prevent
that's right and friction damage to the
car to the motor and moving parts and so
forth same principle here well dialysis
is a problem going on with the
filtration system in the kidneys
okay it filters the blood gets rid of
all the bad stuff turns and it goes into
the urine and out the body that's what
the kidneys do
when you're eating bad stuff what'll
happen is you start damaging the kidneys
and they cannot efficiently do their job
and so
they actually release a hormone which
caused your blood pressure to go up
and so usually when you have dialysis uh
you have a high blood pressure issue and
they'll put you on high blood pressure
medication
and so don't cold trick off your blood
pressure medication when you're on
dialysis
you want to stay away from all the bad
stuff no fried foods no processed meats
no oils no glutens no wheat bran no no
sugar no carbon or drinks even the diet
one's got to go because the carbonation
is still in the diet drinks okay
and then
i want them to have
uh um
two healthy brain heart packs per month
if they weigh 150 pounds or more two
healthy branded heart packs per month to
full dose
twice a day msm two miles a month they
take three practices straight at lunch
at dinner time
and then i want them to have the
ultimate daily classic tablets three of
those twice a day or if they weigh more
than 200
pounds by the way 250 275 300 i'd have
to take three of the ultimate daily
classic
tablets okay three bottles of months i
can take three with each meal
okay and they're gonna support healthy
blood flow through blocked arteries and
support healthy blood pressure it'll
work for the brain the heart the kidneys
all over the place okay so it's not just
the kidneys but it'll work everywhere
and
this will allow for the the kidneys
filtration process to move forward
if you're on high blood pressure
medication for high blood pressure don't
pull turkey off of that but as your
blood pressure begins to drop you can
slowly reduce the medication based on
the number it usually takes about
anywhere from two to six weeks to be
able to wean off of or significantly
drop
the um
prescription drugs for blood pressure
okay
and then people say well how long do i
have to stay on this diet and how long
do i have to stay on this program well
how do you need oxygen forever how long
you need water forever how long you need
the 90 cents of nutrients forever how
long you need your kidneys to work
forever
okay and dialysis
okay just it only does a small portion
of what the kidneys do
um
and basically
uh you know the doctors are worried
about
toxic stuffs accumulating because you're
not yearning properly and so forth and
so that's what they're looking at we're
not looking at all the other pieces
because i don't even know that's
associated with the kidney
okay
and so uh this is very simple stuff
and um
it's one of those things where
we have
again the book rare earthbound cures we
have the book dead doctors don't lie we
have the book epigenetics
and
let's play doctor
okay there's all kinds of books which
answer the questions hell's kitchen it
answers the questions why are we having
these problems they're not genetic
they're not autoimmune they're all due
to nutritional deficiencies okay so you
deal with that
take the nutrients that are necessary to
[Music]
alleviate the problems
and it all goes away
okay
thank you so much for that dr wallach i
appreciate you going more into depth
on the prevention and also
the
the reaction and being able to support
our kidneys so that they can filter the
body as they're designed to do
and
i know when i'm trying to filter stuff
out if i'm not using the right filter or
my filter is not working properly
it's not filtering and things are just
building up and creating sludge and
well
you well you reminded me there's another
issue here
because a lot of times people call me
they'll be in their 60s and 70s and say
uh yeah my name is frank and i've just
been diagnosed with uh diabetes a type 1
diabetes whoa whoa whoa what do you mean
type 1 diabetes where you diagnose the
birthies and no i just diagnosed a
couple of weeks ago i'm
71 years old well kale is not classic
type 1 because classic type 1 is is a
birth defect it's not a genetic birth
defect but
mama's missing nutrients when the
um i'll still hang her hands are forming
um in the pancreas
of the um
uh
of the embryo
okay
and when you have
um
things like um high blood pressure and
diabetes
uh the doctors will
uh give you
um nutrients not nutrients they'll give
you medications
okay
to get things under control and they
they purposely start out by giving you
metformin which is an oral thing well if
you're eating gluten which they know you
are eating pancakes for breakfast and
bread for lunch and
um
bread and noodles and spaghetti for
dinner time and so forth you're getting
a lot of gluten
and so you're not absorbing very well so
you take the metformin orally medication
for for diabetes
and guess what it won't work
so all we gotta you you have type 1 so
we're going to have to give you insulin
so they give them injections and of
course the
injections you can drop the blood sugar
but the reason why people have those
problems is because
um
mama was missing the nutrients
early in pregnancies when you start
getting hyper pressure
the kidneys get involved and so
it's it's a multi-factor issue here with
high blood pressure diabetes and so
forth but it's all totally resolvable
i don't care i take people that haven't
urinated in 10 years they're actually on
dialysis three days a week for 25 years
because they didn't want to get a kidney
transplant
and then the last 10 years
they didn't urinate at all so they
switched them from three dialysis a week
to six
and we put them on our program and in
two weeks time they're urinating so they
drop them back down to three or three
dollars just a week and then two more
weeks they're totally open dialysis
after 25 years being on dialysis
because it's a simple
nutritional deficiency problem
all right and
so
one of the reasons why i brought that up
is
in the chat
somebody's aunt who's 65 years old 93
pounds 5 foot 2
has been on dialysis for 9 years
and it's more and more common
which reminds me of something
that i learned this past week
your wife dr milan whose birthday was
yesterday
was
a microsurgeon
which microsurgeons they're the people
that taken do those kidney transplants
and those fine tiny little
it's just amazing that you can take
something out put something in within
the body it heals
and then it
works so
and she is the co-author of many of your
books
is correct
so you're taking your knowledge and her
knowledge
and putting them all together
and creating these valuable publications
that are
not just somebody's theory not just oh i
thought about that last night i'm going
to write about it this is actual
experience
that's right this is based on
all the clinical experience that she has
all the clinical experience i have plus
32 000 autopsies published
yeah
it's amazing folks the information is
there
all you have to do is reach out and find
it and again at drjwalik.com
you can find all of dr wallach's
publications
and ask doc live
you can find all of the replays for our
programs and i do want to remind you if
somebody shared this program with you
specifically
get back with the person that shared it
with you
they have their own special ways of
ordering
and they want to make sure that you get
the product that you need
and
as a thank you to them
for sharing this program with them
you need to contact them anyways so
get back with them say hi say thank you
that they appreciate
um
you know you appreciate what they did
and taking the time to share this
program with you
so i'm just going through here um i have
keith asking a question what can i do to
lower my psa number with my prostate
that's another big issue with men's
health dr wallach
okay
well the prostate is very active gland
it requires a lot of nutrition
and so again if you're eating gluten
you're not going to be able to absorb
enough nutrition to make the prostate
happy so you got to get off the gluten
and then and then you got to stay away
from fried toots because it oxidizes
fats and and produces bad stuff
um that causes inflammation in the
prostate we do have
the prostaffix
okay take i take three of those twice a
day i don't have any problems but i just
take three twice a day just for
prevention
okay
um and
i also take my three eggs twice a day
for the cholesterol because cholesterol
makes the prostate happy
okay it makes up ninety-five percent of
the weight of testosterone and then i
take three
of the zero test tablets twice it has
two volumes a month of the zero test
is there
fem for the females and is there a test
for the guys i take three of the xeric
tests twice a day that's two bottles a
month and that's the raw materials for
the fertility cells and the testicles to
make testosterone and don't forget the
eggs because the cholesterol on the eggs
is what the
um
what the
excuse me but the sertoli cells
the testicles used to make
um testosterone okay
and same way with the females they can
use the
xerophem
and eat the three eggs twice a day and
they'll be able to make estrogen so
they'll make going through menopause a
lot easier
all right thank you so much dr wallick
um and then we've got another question
here
lots of questions um
carbonation
we know we don't want to have any you
know sugar carbonated drinks no diet
drinks that are carbonated
there are some people that have water
carbonation devices
should they not even have plain
carbonated water and
no carbonation what about the
carbonation
affects or makes it unhealthy
okay the carbonation neutralizes stomach
acid which is required to the stomach
gas is required to be able to absorb
minerals
and also to be able to digest food
your stomach is designed
with special cells called t cells to
make
stomach acid
okay when you have carbonation which
neutralizes stomach acid
your stomach cannot do its job it cannot
digest food and cannot absorb minerals
so you're going to get a double negative
hit if you're constantly drinking
carbonation during the day you know like
soft drinks or juices and
energy drinks and stuff like that
don't do it you don't want any
carbonation
none zero
maybe
um one glass of carbonation
um
you know once a year during your wedding
anniversary
that's it one glass of a year that's it
but not on any regular basis
all right thank you so much dr wallick
and
you know folks you heard it from the man
it messes up with the acid levels within
the digestive system that are needed to
break down food
and and absorb minerals and absorb
minerals
so
if you've got heartburn and all those
good things going on and they just want
to keep throwing these
pharmaceuticals at you
it's not because you
have too much acid in the digestive
system
it's not enough
so we want to make sure we want to make
sure that you're giving the body the
nutrients that it needs
without preventing absorption and
everything's going to start working
better
so i it's simple
it's simple very very simple
and i'm going to be adding on my
co-hosts here because i am super
thankful for my co-host they help make
everything run smoothly dr wallach and
there's nasima
so folks
there she is
um on behalf of ask stock live and the
astock live team
we are
just honored to be able to bring this
program to you
it's passion of each of our hearts
each of us have experienced something
within our own health journey that that
man right there
he's on my left
on the screen
has been so instrumental in helping us
reclaim
health
and enjoy life
you can have it too you can see we're
all different ages here
it's not just for the young it's not
just for the old it's not just for those
that are already sick
it's for everybody
and as parents grandparents yes i'm a
grandma four times over
it's our duty
to share this information
to help
our grandchildren our great
grandchildren not have to experience
the pain and dis-ease
that we around the world
have come to accept as normal
it does not have to be normal
let's change the norm
and create healthier communities
everywhere we go
so get back with the person that shared
this program with you
if you have never spoken to anybody
about youngevity or the 90 for life
information
we have so many followers on different
radio programs our newsletter with
critical health news
that if
you found this program on your own
reply
to the email if you got an email
but we do have a call team that's also
standing by at 855-949-7234
we are here to help you
get what you need
to have
oh that's my radio program i won't say
that
okay to have a better by the minute life
yes
everywhere we go there are things that
we can do we can be empowered
to create
a better by the minute life
so everybody on behalf of askdoc live
thank you
any of my co-hosts want to say any
closing remarks
just waves
i just want to thank everyone for coming
and being part of askdoc live
and all of us
do have
very intense stories of recovery
by using dr wallach's programs
thank thank you for sharing
yeah wonderful thank you for being here
everyone and we'll see you again next
week do invite others as well and if
your questions didn't get answered today
because of the time restrictions please
tune in again and you can reach us
through our contact us
on askdoclive.com
website
this is why i need co-hosts thank you
nasima
[Laughter]
i don't think i mentioned that today but
everybody have a very very blessed
blessed rest of this week and we'll see
you next time on ask stock live bye for
now bye bye
bye bye